one of the reasons i left the u.s is
because i was disappointed coming back
into this negative sphere but seeing the
good i can finally say the things that
have actually really been bothering me
china is testing my limits
getting harassed all the time just doing
something like this you just don't have
anything to compare it with
so you take it for granted they want to
speak they're censoring themselves
because they know there's trouble that's
the worst right yeah
if you step out of line if you speak
against the government you're done you
and your family are done
it's not even a communist country they
don't have any social programs what
would you tell like the average person
who's getting this pessimistic view of
the us
all right here i am with
matt tai of lao y 86 he's got a
fantastic youtube channel about all
things chinese
and today i thought it'd be a great idea
to get a conversation with them we're
here in carlsbad
near san diego we met up here both live
in different cities but we had to meet
up in a nice place
and i wanted to talk to matt about his
take on the u.s
after living abroad for what 10 years
yeah 10 years
in taiwan i lived abroad i just got back
from four years abroad but 10 years is a
serious stint
and he was in deep for those that don't
know his channel uh he was in deep
in china speaks fluent chinese and
i think has done one of the deepest
dives i've seen online
all things china related sure and
how does it feel i'm just going to start
with that how does it feel being back
you've been back what two years now yeah
so i'll be honest with you i was
dreading it i mean one of the reasons i
left
the us is because i was disappointed and
that's that's the truth of the the whole
thing is that when i left in 2008
i was i was over this place you know i
traveled around i had bit i had
i was in debt from college yeah and i
was like is this all there is is
you live the white picket fence stream
you know right you pay off the your
college that for the rest of your life
um and that's pretty much where i was at
so i was i was thinking about
what can i do outside of this i just
backed back through europe right i
wanted more of that so
i ended up trying to move to taiwan
ended up in china but um
when i got back here it was a completely
different story
when i got back here i saw everything
not from a 21 22 year old's eyes anymore
right it was a realistic it was sobering
it was a realistic perspective that
not that not that i did i had it so good
before and now i see
like what i was missing right it's more
like from an outside perspective when
you live away from this country for so
long
you can see the generality the general
nature of america is what you make of it
instead of oh this is what i'm supposed
to do this is what mom and dad did
right i can come back here with a new
renewed perspective from being abroad
for so long and say listen i can do so
much here and america affords me so many
opportunities
right it's a massive benefit of the
country whereas i was
china was testing my limits of what i
could do what i could get away with
right
i was going around shooting these
documentaries and swat team
pla police at every corner getting
harassed all the time
just having just doing something like
that just doing something like this
right
just going around like i was up filming
camels up in inner mongolia and
the next thing you know what i'm uh
being interrogated by the swat team and
the people's liberation army right okay
it's it's those sobering moments when
you realize
holy [ __ ] right like the fact that i
can't just go have
and i'm already tiptoeing around my
subject matter in china right right
i'm only covering positive things
because i know what'll happen to me
otherwise
right so when you come back here and you
realize you can do all of those things
it wakes you up
it wakes you up like wow number two
my neighborhood in upstate new york is
not america
everywhere every single place in america
is completely different yeah yeah
so if i wanted to integrate and and talk
to people of different cultures and
stuff
that's all here right that's everywhere
right it's so much more multicultural
than china is
right but my perspective is somebody who
left
uh back in 2008 was that it's just my
hometown
right you can travel around and stuff
but unless you live in a place you won't
fully understand it
traveling is different exactly right
yeah living in and it's it's almost like
a relationship when you're dating
right like everything's great in the
beginning right like the the part the
person can do no wrong
right and then time starts you know
revealing the truth of it right
and it is it a good fit or not yes
that's exactly what it is you want to go
to the beach yeah yeah sure
cool all right so go to the beach i mean
i i've been watching peter's stuff for a
long time now
and um i'll be honest with you our
perspective on things is probably quite
similar but
the way that we portray things is a
little different yeah but i think that's
very necessary
sure because i like to watch your stuff
because you are a bastion of positivity
in a very negative way
right i'm trying and trying what you are
it keeps my sanity
sure to some degree i think that's
fantastic right
one thing that differs i would say is
that when i was
when i was in china for 10 years i loved
it i loved every minute of it and i
thought it was fascinating it pushed me
to my limits but i also made me who i am
today
right and i have to thank china for that
experience that being said
because of those experience because it
pushed me to the limits of what i could
do
coming back here has been like a burden
has been lifted because i can finally
say the things that have
actually really been bothering me i'm
not talking about toilets or something
right i'm talking about like the real
real bad stuff that was going on
uh due to the communist party of china
and yes my channel's taking a focus on
that just because i think it's so
necessary to talk about
yeah yeah and so there's always that
like you were saying earlier
traveling is one thing living is another
yeah and
ukraine and china are two different
worlds i lived in in kiev ukraine
and uh i was free to speak whatever it's
actually a very freeing place sure
i'd say there are even less rules in the
states for sure in many ways right
ways yeah um my challenges there were
different overall i love the culture i
love the people
um the government did not interfere with
me right uh it was things like
air pollution yeah you know like
breathing clean air is getting headaches
right or things just just not working or
some oligarch
can you know this is a new complex here
yeah and someone can put up another one
here pay off the right guy
all of a sudden the water's not working
so well over there i get you those types
of stories that sort of add up they they
add up and then you realize
when you when you grow up in the state
you you just don't have anything to
compare it with
so you take it for granted yes but until
you lose those things
yes yeah and they start to make your
life more difficult then you're like
oh my god this is this is an amazing
thing
right and i want to say also that like
um
in these times we're in where it's a
very negative sort of uh
bitter look at the us online especially
right yeah and we have all sorts of
challenges and problems
i mean these are very evident right a
lot of the good is getting overlooked
yes absolutely and that's the thing
that's so frustrating is that
coming back into this negative sphere
but seeing the good
seeing what's so amazing about it right
is exactly what's in
it's it's infuriating i'll be totally
honest but it's also my
my job and your job as well not to
convince people that the us is a good
place
right but to show the reasons maybe as
to why right and maybe inspire some
people to take advantage of their
situation
yes um yes we are considered privileged
maybe in this country right
compared to to other groups of people
especially that's the current dialogue
right now
right that being said despite all of
those things people keep saying
well this shows america's weakness this
shows how america is gonna fall it's
like the empire it's like the roman
empire
right these are all the signs the
telltale signs of the fallen empire
to me all of this turmoil uh-huh number
one doesn't compare to china
the stuff i've seen in china people
aren't allowed to talk about
right but number two shows the strength
to me
of this country the fact that people can
be so divided
and at each other's throat seemingly
right on the media but it's still a
cohesive country that continues to work
yeah and operate and people can still do
what they want to do
and address those issues to me that's a
beautiful thing and
i you know sometimes we all do it right
we get on the rabbit hole of the
internet right and you go down you're
like oh it's looking really bad out
there and then i'm driving around the
streets and i'm like yeah
okay we're in california we're seeing
homeless people like that's
like they're here there are big problems
yes but
look at this look at this life like is
anyone coming at our throats
no i'm talking with people from all
different backgrounds every day
i don't feel any tension in that but if
you're if you're constantly poking
through the online world
it's like wow it's coming down really
quickly right kovit hasn't helped this
now everyone's
like inside on on the virtual world yeah
and so what i'm doing i think what
you're doing is capturing
the real world and and putting into the
virtual world yes
obviously it's coming through our lenses
like there's always a bias right
i'm trying to look at things as an
optimist uh sometimes i'll get into the
dirt
sure like i made a video recently about
san francisco she's pissed off on how
bad i got
it i think it's great that you do that i
felt like i had to but you can do that
that's the difference right right right
right so there's no perfect place i like
i like to always make that very clear to
my audience and whoever's watching these
videos
like there's no perfect place i feel
like the us is a wonderful place
if you want to if you really want to
realize yourself sure
if you want to experiment if you want to
not be judged
yeah for what you're doing oh they would
tell you otherwise though wouldn't they
right right right
like i'm in my 40s making youtube videos
that is not cool in uh
most of the world and maybe not to some
of you out there but uh no it works
right and you can you can recreate and
you can reinvent
you can try different things you can do
you can do some real estate and make
youtube videos at the same
time there's so many options and the
culture which i want to
mention is very important and you cannot
read really about this
or see it as a tourist but what's
expected in a culture and how
restrictive that can be
right so for example i don't want to
totally you know nail it italy i love
italy
sure but there are many there's more
there's more like
rigidity to what you need to be to
so-called be successful in life right
right right yeah like you need to take
like an italian mom telling you
you're doing a youtube channel probably
isn't going to go over well with most
most italian moms right and the
interesting thing too
is a lot of americans and my myself
included before i always thought europe
was like
oh they have it so much better in europe
sure right i was like oh europe
look at they got the the piazzas they
got their cafes
it's exactly the same it's like look at
that perfect life they have the
lifestyle
right and if you do want a three-hour
lunch break yeah
italy is way better than here right i'll
admit
i get that's got to get old after a
while for me for my personality or your
personality that or anyone that's like
really driven
i think that gets old right yeah and
also a lot of people don't know
a good salary in italy is two grand a
month right
right that's like a good salary right
people like wow that person makes two
grand a month sure
and i think i made that when i was
mowing lawns oh yeah 16 year old yeah
yeah
something like that in the summers right
so
there's a lot of i'm not going to say
miss out misinformation but that grass
is always greener mentality
right and i suggest to anyone to go
experience the world
and live in the world sure like you and
i both did and then you make your own
decisions right
but what i want to ask you is we're in
these times now i mean especially the
last year
it's been a shock for me coming back
into it sort of this censorship
mentality
sure like stick with the narrative
mentality
scared to speak mentality sure china's
taken
that course right did you say over the
last five years or so yeah
do you feel like america is following
in that sense at all or is totally
different i think it's wildly different
but that is something that everyone asks
me because they see
they basically say listen matt i feel
like
what you're saying about the chinese
government currently in your videos is
exactly what's happening
right right now here in the us and i
gotta say it's very different because
can't like cancel culture for example
right the chinese government uses cancer
culture at a state level
right so if you step out of line if you
speak against the government you're done
you and your family are done it's a
thuggish regime right
cancer culture here is driven by this
obsession with social media
okay this obsession with being famous is
the obsession with
having power over another human being
but i don't think that's entered the
political sphere as much as you might
think
okay i think down if you really took it
like a legal case for example
if people use defamation and things like
that it's actually really hard
to sue someone for something dumb here
right like defamation things like that
so that kind of ties into the whole
cancer culture thing however i do see
culturally
a censorship taking over i see people
buying into that and just accepting it
okay based on what it's going to do to
their image online
okay or maybe at work right now the
reason i say it's so different again is
that it's
a state level versus a private level
it's social pressure versus a
an actual government that will [ __ ] you
up right right right so that's that's
the biggest difference here and i don't
want to people i don't want people to
equival
i don't want people to equate those two
things together
you're not living in an authoritarian
police state in the u.s and that's one
thing i'm just so tired of is that
oh it looks like we're just becoming
exactly like dr seuss being cancelled or
whatever right okay
that would that was amazon in the
publisher right
the public government not the government
right but in china it's the government
cancelling those things
not just books but anything any
sentiment any mild distaste for the
government right
so you as an american if i'm speaking to
americans mostly
yeah you still have the right to do most
things right that hasn't been taken away
from you yet
right whether you decide to feed into
that toxic mentality of social media and
the way things are going currently
uh-huh something i refuse to do but if
you're feeding into that then you're
part of the problem as well
right but it's an honest choice it's an
honest choice
but if you're at a workspace maybe or a
corporate america and like there's sort
of protocols you have to
suck that's right that sucks i have
friends in those situations and i
understand that and that's that's a real
that's a real thing
um when you talk about that but again
it's not the state leaning down on
people for that right
yeah now if you're talking about how far
corporate america has gone and the
influence that it controls the workplace
or the way
people act in general yeah that's that's
a massive issue but it's also a separate
issue
right yeah it's something that i feel
like people need to take
take up on their own and gather together
and come to the consensus that hey maybe
we should
hold on to our freedoms right yeah and
not let a dollar or amazon tell us what
to do
right so yeah i mean it's different and
i guess it's a little
similar it's a little similar but mostly
different but for me i realize how
important that is after being in many
parts i've been in countries where
people
you're in a great conversation it goes
political
and all of a sudden there's like this
tent they like clench jaws like yeah
they want to speak but they just they're
they're censoring themselves because
they know there's trouble from the
government
and that's like that's the worst right
yeah that's like
the biggest breach of sovereignty yes
you know that a human can experience i
think it's when you cannot speak
yeah i think there's this fallacy
actually it's a massive one i think
there's this fallacy that like a lot of
people would be like
listen you just got in trouble in china
because you were speaking out number one
i wasn't
right i was really actually just towing
the party line at that point
right but the fact that i would bring up
anything societally
was enough to throw the for them to
throw the book at me right so there was
you know the average person might say
listen if you just don't talk about
politics then you're fine right
and that's missing the point right yes
maybe if you go to a country where it's
illegal to talk about politics you
probably shouldn't talk about politics
right
that being said that's not that's that's
a slippery slope that's not the way
society should run
right nothing's off limits for a private
conversation that's just ridiculous
right and that's not an american
exceptionalism or privilege or whatever
but
coming back to america you can see how
good people actually have the luxuries
of being able to say what they want to
say
what would you tell young people that
feel they don't like
some people legit legitimately have it
bad i've been to their hoods
absolutely like they're growing up in
difficult conditions they're people in
very difficult circumstances
but overall i'd say we're a country
about 330 million people
what would you tell like the average
young person who's getting this
pessimistic view of the us
and its place in the world or however
you want to take that
i tell them i had to walk snow uphill
both ways
you know obviously people are going to
look at a 34 year old and be like okay
boomer but
yeah yeah yeah i don't look at it from
the perspective of our ages look at it
from the perspective of we've already
seen the world
right yeah it's not a flex that's a real
thing when you see outside person when
you have an outside perspective and you
live
amongst a situation that's wildly
different from yours back home
you can see how things work and i'm not
going to tell a kid in the hood
that he has a good i'm not gonna be like
damn you are so you're
you're on the right trajectory
everything's gonna be awesome right
right right the state probably isn't
gonna take care of you by and large
right that's just that's the nature of
the beast right
however the opportunities outside of
your impoverished situation maybe your
family situation and stuff
remain better than the majority of the
rest of the world right
and i understand it sucks to have
somebody say like
listen you just gotta pull through and
get out of it right right now what i'm
trying to say what i'm trying to say is
that you do have a toolbox here
outside of your personal situation to
make a change
you do and that's something that people
in other countries in particular in my
case in china
you know that people always talk about
oh chinese people have it so good
because they love their government and
that they're taking care of them number
one their government's not taking care
of them
and they're 95 percent now it's not
socialist communists
so people think it's not even a
communist country they don't have any
social programs
let's jump over here sure let's just uh
get away from this crane
if you're poor in china you die there's
not there's not food banks here there's
not a ymca
you understand there's not a government
program that's handing out stipend left
and right
to poor people right it's cut throat as
hell it's more cut throat than the u.s
right so what i'm saying is that the
so-called approval rating of people in
china that approve of their governments
like authoritarian lead
is 95 that's [ __ ] you can't say you
don't approve the government and it's 95
percent apathy
from what i've seen because you can't do
anything about it right
so when you talk about an american down
and out american that has
a really bad luck like lot in life yeah
you still have the toolbox in the us
to make something of yourself yeah you
still have it you still have free
education
maybe it sucks but you're still better
than most of the rest of the world and
that comparison might not be useful to
you right now
but it's one of those things that became
useful to me after i left right right
right
so i didn't have like some awful
childhood right i grew up very middle
class
yeah but even that leaving that and then
coming back i was like what an idiot i
was
to not take all these opportunities and
advantages that i had yeah
yeah yeah you just don't know until you
see something do you see it from a
different perspective correct
you just don't know you don't know what
dress feels shoes feel like until you
you know you get into running shoes and
then you go back to your dress shoes
that's exactly correct
so all right we could go on forever we
have a lot of
china themes but i'm going to direct you
guys to matt's channel because he goes
in deep he presents him very well
it's one of my favorite channels on
youtube thank you i'll leave the link
below
all right hopefully we uh brought some
spirits up today but if you are
questioning the us
it's always good to question everything
uh and if you have a chance
go out get some world experience yes
maybe you like it more out there maybe
you stay and that's great
or maybe you look at here in your own
life in a different way
i did it my 20s best move ever made yeah
agreed
all right thanks matt no problem
you